[Musique]
chivu
dieu nous ramène à un homme relit avec
autant de joie que la première fois sa
lettre d'acceptation dans la faculté de
médecine de l'université de toronto
ils sont 26 noir d'une courte de 259
étudiants admis à la faculté de médecine
de l'université de toronto
une première au canada historiquement
les noirs ont été tous représentés dans
les 17 facultés de médecine au pays au
début des années 90 la docteure listera
benson a côtoyé qu'une poignée
d'étudiants noirs en médecine à
l'université toronto en 2016 elle
constate que peu de choses ont changé
depuis ses études cette année la chica
au roi est la seule noire de sa
promotion
alors que les noirs représentent 7 5% de
la population de la ville reine devenu
vice doyenne du bureau de la diversité
et de l'inclusion de la faculté de
médecine
dr robinson et son équipe créé le
programme d'admission d'étudiants noirs
leur objectif faire tomber certains des
barrières qui empêchent les étudiants
noirs de soumettre leur candidature les
exigences académiques demeurent les
mêmes
cependant les candidats noirs doivent
rédiger une lettre expliquant pourquoi
ils ont choisi ce processus d'admission
autre différence le comité de sélection
compte des personnes noires en 2018
le programme recrute 15 étudiants noirs
puis 15 autres en 2019 et 26 pour la
rentrée 2020 macrolides tesfaye
étudiante de deuxième année et
coprésidente de l'association des
étudiants noirs en médecine ne peut
s'empêcher de sourire
ce changement avait pourtant été entamée
au début du 20e siècle
entre 1900 et 1918 près de 60 noir ont
étudié à la faculté de médecine de
l'université queen's à kingston en
ontario
selon les recherches de twitter mais ce
candidat au doctorat en études
culturelles ces étudiants avaient du
succès en dépit de la discrimination
qu'il subissait en 1918 pour tomber dans
les bonnes grâces de l'association
médicale américaine
queens interdit les études en médecine
ou noir
le département compte quinze étudiants
noirs seulement la moitié d'entre eux
réussissent à compléter leur parcours
académique
c'est le début du déclin à changer nos
pratiques
la docteure ognier honorum président de
l'association des médecins noir de
l'ontario et professeur à l'université
de toronto est d'avis que d'inclure plus
d'étudiants noirs dans les facultés de
médecine améliorant la qualité des soins
offerts aux patients noirs qu'ils
subissent de la discrimination dans le
système de santé au canada
c'est vraiment avoir des personnes qui
peuvent comprendre des différentes
expérience culturelle des expériences de
discrimination dans un rapport publié en
un groupe de recherche de l'onu
concluent que les afro canadiens sont
touchés de façon disproportionnée par
les inégalités qui contribuent à des
taux élevés de maladies chroniques
c'est de ne pas être d'arriver à
l'urgence avec la douleur puis s'est pas
autant traiter haute pas traité comme il
faut les étudiants blancs gagneront
aussi à côtoyer plus de futurs médecins
noir selon m
mais ce n'est pas tout d'avoir des
coureurs diversifié médecins et
étudiants noirs exige des curriculums
d'enseignement inclusif entre autres en
dermatologie des changements se dessine
à l'horizon les facultés de médecine de
l'université de calgary et celle de
l'alberta ont annoncé la mise en place
l'an prochain d'un programme d'admission
pour les étudiants noirs au québec
l'université mcgill et l'université de
montréal sont en processus de
réévaluation de leur plan d'action en
juin dernier la docteure chicao les oies
a été élu par ses pairs nous prononcer
le discours d'adieu de sa promotion
grâce aux trois points
pour ce qui est de mohammed ghanem
l'avenir lui appartient